[Music]
so let's let's do a story in two parts
on what he's thank you Marsh for finding
this now this is the Prelude like you
said this is first correct yeah because
you say yeah
I got a little yeah perfect so we have a
little connecting story here each of us
got a different part of this okay so
let's just play this this is the king
without the sting but the wing
this is uh Brendan Schaub and his new
person he's emulating crystalia
I gotta go to a funeral tomorrow man
well that'll that's plugged that oh I
think they're live streaming it that was
pretty funny that was actually just
objectively very funny I got my
grandma's funeral I'll be selling merch
which again at this point
look it's the joke is stupid but I'm not
offended or anything man I get why he's
saying it
is it really uh okay I mean she was 98
October 28th Colusa making up casinos
dude um so that's sad I'm sorry ah don't
be oh I wasn't that close with her my
dad's like one of 13. you know she's
cool she's 98 and also 300. you're in
pain and you're being defensive yeah you
might be right I'll do my little she
used to swim every day though there you
go even at 98 used to swim like a
freaking wall or something no it's your
dad's do walrus swim well yeah walruses
swim but I mean not walrus is swimming
they swim well but that's not a phrase
nobody goes man you know that that
Michael Phelps you know he swims like a
walrus
it's you know it's like a fish you swim
like a fish right
shark a dolphin maybe a dolphin but a
walrus
okay so it's your dad's mom yeah and he
was one of 13 bro one of 13. oh I have
like many kids I was busting that much
and having like that's crazy religious
super religious and just just so let me
um
I want to point a few things out about
this a little weird
first of all like Anna don't be sad I
wasn't really that closer
um yeah my dad was one of 13 they were
really religious so how are you not
close with your grandmother because I've
seen like Italian and Hispanic families
where they have 75 siblings and they're
all Catholic and yeah it's a big family
it's hard to keep track of everything
but they're all still usually at least
close during the holidays at least
holidays at least holidays yeah like
it's just odd that he's around 13
siblings how do you even keep up with
your mom and you're like I mean you
would though right [ __ ] buddy Dodge
that we used to do radio with
14 kids in his family remember Dutchess
one of 14. and they're super close and
they're always so glad that's [ __ ]
[Music]
okay so it comes at the end okay no no
but no no no but but you got to get the
good cop there it is so
this is what he uh after that thing this
is what I saw this on Instagram I just
happened to see it on Instagram and
um this is from his page this isn't as
somebody pointed out uh as people have
been pointing out this is this seems
like something like the the fighter and
the kids subreddit will post on put one
on one of his photos but this is what he
wrote
Brendan put this up and here's what it
says
funeral fit I'm going to read it like he
wrote it okay so if it's not I'm saying
it wrong I'm reading that he wrote it
okay ready funeral fit my grandma would
want me to flex on my family
just tad just Tad not a tad just Tad
all right so I gotta be honest because
everybody was like you know kind of
outraged about this um
I wasn't as offended by the Instagram
post like just because it's like all
right I could I could see making a silly
joke at a funeral you know whatever it's
the stuff leading up to it that was
weird like that I'll be sad I ain't
known a [ __ ]
that was a little more weird just the
fact that he has no he was clear he has
no relationship with this woman well
then then why go to the funeral but
first off but secondly if you're gonna
go to the funeral do that but the other
side the other way I look at this is
this you're right me and you aren't
offended but now let's look at it from a
different perspective
your stad mom brother cousin and and you
go look I get this is funny for
everybody else but that was my you know
my grandma you know that was my mother
you know like I get you have your little
show you know because I'm looking to get
from my perspective if it was somebody
in my family that I'd be pissed you
would have to be right you'd be like bro
this is our family business like what
the [ __ ] are you doing dude not
everything's a little thing for your
stupid [ __ ] show and now I'm not
offended by it I mean I get the joke I'm
not I'm not trying to be [ __ ] [ __ ]
about it I understand uh where the joke
is but you can't then later claim I'm a
good guy I'm a good guy I'm a nice guy
I'm a good guy right and then oh yeah no
that's that's the thing but I'm saying
like in in content like this this to me
on I saw this and I kind of chuckled I
was like I don't know it's kind of money
whatever but like if it would work for
me if he was like what like Jim Norton
used to be or Jim Jefferies used to be
or like Patrice was like if Patrice had
posted this I'd be [ __ ] hysterical
because like he would never go
he wouldn't waste like an hour of his
breath every day on his show trying to
sell everybody like you said on what a
good dude he is like just be a piece of
[ __ ] and embrace and be funny but like
you know he's gonna go right back to
like yo people took us out of context oh
you know what I mean like like whatever
shall make joke be well that's and by
the way that's not a sister that's his
wife's people don't know that also honey
you could take a little bit more
eyebrows off
a little bit more
I know you had the the Mexican unibrow
thing going but come on come on
sweetheart let's let's maybe take care
of that a little bit no they took off as
much as they could they said if they
took off any more she'd died that's
right okay fair enough that's true I
forgot I forgot about bam we can't take
any more eyebrow off we don't know
what's gonna happen I think one of
them's connected to your arteries I
don't know what to do we took enough
hair off around your eyebrows to donate
it to Locks of Love